hey guys welcome back to brand-new Veda
we're back on eight packs legends again
and we're gonna be talking about the
newest patch that is gonna be going live
today as about 1 p.m. and it's about
3:30 when I'm recording this so so this
should be live by the time this video is
up those lattes like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe here for new and during
the discord in Twitter if you want and
let's get started
so first up it might seem a little bit
confusing how in the thumbnail end of
the title of the video it says something
about 30 X 30 thousand XP or something
like that that will all be explained in
a minute so don't worry I'm not trying
to clickbait you this is some real [ __ ]
so let me just get to the video and
explain and then you can leave your
comments down below after that but this
is gonna be patched 1.1.1 this is gonna
have some legend balancing x' a new
event coming and a lot of other stuff on
the legend balancing front they of
course want to adjust Gibraltar caustic
and Pathfinder the three biggest hip
boxes within the game Gibraltar and
caustic will now get a new perk added to
their general passive called fortified
which reduces their damage taken by 10%
so caustics passive is that he can walk
through the NOx gas without being
affected and gibraltars passive gun
shield that also counts to a top of
eating the 10% damage reduction caustic
is now going to be receiving gas damage
per tick increasing and his ultimate
throw range so if his gas per tick is
originally one what a damage per tick I
do believe it goes from 2 to 3 to 4 to 5
etc but I think now it's going to jump
up by 4 so it could be going for 8 12 16
and 20 and all the other multiples
before making his gas damage a lot more
useful and of course is going to be
chucking his ultimate from 33 meters as
opposed to 28 so just a small increase
on that and then the only thing for
Gibraltar is besides of course the 10%
damage reduction his gun shield health
is now going to be increased from 50 to
75 so just 25 more ticks of health to
the gun show which is always a good
thing
one thing they did not mention that's
something that I have been seeing is
that apparently on pathfinders legs
and/or arms from what I've heard from
the community and new pro player
community is that Pathfinder actually
has a bug where he cannot take damage
from either the legs the arms or both I
do I don't actually remember which one
it is but it is one of his limbs where
it just does not take any damage and it
[ __ ] with his hitbox they haven't
addressed this and I hope that they do
address this eventually soon because it
is a bit annoying
in terms of weapon balance we have the
g7 Scout the triple take the longbow the
havoc the wingman the Spitfire and the
gold variations of a couple weapons so
let's rifle through this real quick for
the g7 the triple take and the longbow
it is gonna be lowered leg shot damage
reduction by 12 from 25% to 10% the
reduced base weapons sway and the base
sway speed is about 33% and then 25%
respectively meaning you're gonna be
doing a lot more damage than the legs
then originally but not of course as
much as a body shot or a head shot and
the sway speed for the weapon and you
sway in general is going to be a little
less dramatic allowing you to aim those
shots a lot better for the longbow
specifically they increase the mag size
from five rounds to six rounds the
common extended mag is gonna have eight
instead of six the blue version is gonna
have ten and ten instead of eight and
the epic or the purple mag is gonna have
12 instead of ten so in order it's going
to be from base mag to the highest
amount of extended mag it's gonna be six
rounds eight rounds ten rounds then
twelve rounds they also increased the
fire rate of the longbow from one point
two to one point six mean you could
shoot a little bit faster than normal
next up is the havoc and it got a little
bit of a buff to its mag size is now 32
rounds instead of 25 which is an amazing
buff I can't stand having their fact be
no extended back on this weapon and I
have to do with 25 rounds the whole game
the charge beam or the one that you get
with the select fire receiver the one
that probably nobody uses and I'll cost
four rounds instead of five to use it
has also increased the damage at close
range and the damage at range by about
five damage each while also increasing
the range of the fall-off meaning you
can get a lot more damage from a much
larger distance and not having a drop
really dramatically next up we have the
wingman in the Spitfires the basically
the kings of the heavy round section and
they both got nerfs the wingman got a
reduced magazine size it is now four
rounds instead of six on the basic and
then going all the way up from common
rare and epic it's gonna be six rounds
instead of eight eight rounds and seven
nine and ten rounds instead of twelve so
it's gonna be about one to two bullets
less per mag that you're gonna be
getting which kind of sucks but I feel
like this wingman therefore might be a
little bit justified but I've seen a lot
of people use the Spitfire of which
we'll get into in a second for the
Spitfire the base damage has been
decreased it is now 18 damage per shot
instead of 20 and then
with the mag extender it is now 40
rounds 45 rounds and 55 rounds instead
of 45 55 and 60 basically meaning for
both guns are gonna have less ammo to
shoot per clip which is gonna suck and
for the Spitfire you're gonna be doing a
little bit less damage personally I do
don't I really don't mind the wingman
nerf I wish this came a little bit
earlier and I don't really enjoy the
fact that they nerfed the fire rate
because of the nerfing of the fire and
getting rid of the how much it pops up
in game a lot of people have been using
this bit fire which is probably why the
Spitfire just got nerfed recently now
probably my favourite weapon balancing
out of this entire patch is the gold
weapons so the gold havoc now has the
turbocharger as opposed to before where
it had the select fire the gold havoc
now has a one to two variable holo sight
as opposed to the 2 to 4 times I believe
it had the gold r3o one also has the 1
to 2 times variable as opposed to the 2
to 4 and the gold wingman now has a
digital threat scope so all the stuff
that we've really been asking for
personally I'd rather much have just a
one time Talos site not a big fan of the
variable zooms but I am very glad that
the havoc finally has a turbocharger
because let's be honest no one really
used the select-fire it was just the
shitty triple take at that point but as
always that was a lot of numbers and it
might be hard to keep up with so if you
do want to see the entire patch I'll
leave it linked in the description if
you want to follow along or understand
what I was saying cuz maybe I'm speaking
a little bit too fast I need to
apologize for that next up is the battle
pass bonus event XP and this is gonna be
running from today at around 1:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time or 10:00 p.m.
Pacific time to about April 18th at
around the same time so about 1 p.m. est
or 10:00 p.m. PST you can of course
check the link in the description if you
want to see your better times and stuff
like that if you live somewhere in the
Europe or in Australia but basically if
you're in the top five you're going to
beginning an entire battle past level
which is 29,500 battle past points and
that can increase you up to I think
about three levels because I do believe
that this game is going or this event is
going on for about three days and you
can only get this once per day so you
won't be GISS if you just log on get top
5 for the next three days I believe
you'll just gain about three ranks which
is why I included the 30000 because of
course that has to take into account the
amount of XP that you gain during that
match and one battle past level is about
twenty nine point five K and then of
course it's not that hard to get 500 or
5,000 XP so you can
they get 30000 XP in one day just by
getting to the top 5 for this weekend
and then also for some additional
changes they fixed a couple UI bugs that
showed some wrong percentages of the
Boost badges and they also increased the
speed of the dropship by 50% this is so
that people that want to drop later or
their favorite position is later in the
drop they don't have to wait so long to
get it yeah but let me know what you
guys think about this update I also
forgot to mention that they will be
trying to add more of these battle XP
bonuses throughout the season which is
nice and we're finally getting some
in-game content to actually do for the
season I thought we're gonna go three
months without absolutely anything so
I'm very glad this is actually happening
electively if he did subscribe if you're
new I covered the informational side of
apex legend so if you want to be kept
updated with everything happening within
the world of apex legend stuff we stay
subscribe the channel my two most recent
apex videos gonna be popping up on
screen
and with that take care guys have a
great rest today and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]